hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you to another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so in
this video we're going to be talking
about is how to use the quotient rule
when you're calculating derivatives so
first of all what is a quotient rule huh
well the quotient just means that you're
dividing one quantity by another
quantity right as a quotient and you can
see I've written the formula over here
at some vu prime minus UV prime divided
by V squared now that's a little bit
complicated and a lot of books and a lot
of teachers will actually teach this
little rhyme as a way of remembering it
and I found this very helpful and I
think you will too what you do is you
say low D high so that means you take
the one that's low in the denominator
times the derivative of what's in the
numerator that's high that's above right
so low D high minus high D low so high
times the derivative of what's you know
below in the denominator over the square
of what's below so let's just say that
again so it's low D high minus high D
low over the square of what's below low
D high minus high D low over the square
of what's below low D high minus high D
low over the square of what's below ok
let me show you how that works so we've
got the rhyme down right so you want to
take the derivative of this quotient
write the two quantities divided so what
you would do is you'd say kalo x squared
d high that's the derivative of cosine
which is negative sine - hi that's
cosine of X cosine X D low derivative of
x squared is 2x over the square of
what's below so that's going to be x
squared squared or X to the fourth now
you can go back and simplify that but
let's just practice taking the
derivative using the quotient rule
okay this example here same idea we've
got low D high so derivative of 5x minus
3 is 5 minus high D low derivative X
square plus 1 is 2x over the square of
what's below so that's x squared plus 1
squared so we're not taking the
derivative denominator we're just
squaring it
ok last example
we've got low that's what's in the
denominator X plus 3d high which is 2 X
plus 2
- hi that's just the entire the
numerator
DLO derivative X plus 3 is 1 over the
square of what's below so that's going
to be X plus 3 the quantity squared and
you can go back and simplify but I just
wanted to get you in the routine of
following that quotient rule pattern and
again just remembering the little rhyme
to help you with that low D high minus
high D low over the square of what's
below subscribe to the channel check out
some of my past videos I'll see you in
the next video I'll talk to you soon